Nicki Minaj you're in a music video with
Nicki Minaj tell me how can you just
tell me that phone call like did you
call her did you text her like what
happened so I mean this is okay so my my
former college roommate uh who was going
to be an engineer loved film and
television and I was an absolute
nightmare to room with and I was like
dude
you got to get into the movie business
like you love it like so he quits he
quits being an engineer ends up
producing music videos and has literally
worked his way up to producing like the
biggest music videos in the business and
he called me was like Alexander we
really really need a guy for this
Nikki's team likes you for this will you
do it
and I was like well you only live once
and you know I'm a fan of her music and
you know her team and and I were mutual
fans of each other so
um I'm grateful I did it I was like it's
a it's a crazy thing to be able to say
you did yeah and I love that you're
getting into country music talk a little
bit about your love of country music and
what is it that made you say you know
what at this time of my life I I want to
do that when I finished Vikings I had
time on my hands and I started taking
trips to Nashville uh just to write
because I love I love country music it
was like the skeleton in my closet and
long story short I ended up sitting
right behind these guys on a plane who
were fans of Lone Survivor and it was
Jason Aldean's band we talked the entire
way and they were like uh by the time
they heard my music they were like we
have to work together
um I mean so many actors try to do both
and it can be cringe at times so for me
I don't that's the truth anymore no
that's the thing is I think that if this
was 15 years ago it would have been
impossible uh but now you know I'm just
whatever comes of it I'm just grateful
to be able to do it you know and I love
music I've been writing my whole life so
uh to have this opportunity is amazing
and we'll just see what happens I mean
it seems like people are loving what
we're putting out so that's that's what
matters so listen you got to be in a
Nicki Minaj video so then can I be in
your music video if if you I would be
honored oh my gosh you have to wear this
though I will wear this okay I'm gonna
do it right done absolutely okay perfect
we'll call it Canadian cowgirl I'll
start writing it now perfect okay I'm
very excited call me okay everyone